des électeurs rassemblés devant les
bureaux de vote de philadelphie en
pennsylvanie des pros trump des pro by
day tous réunis pour dénoncer le vol de
l'élection par le camp adverse avec des
slogans opposé stopper le décompte ou
compter chaque vote selon la couleur du
candidat supporter nous avons une
administration qui annonce sans vergogne
qu'elle va ignorer les véritables
résultats de cette élection et essayer
de voler l'élection à celui qui je pense
est le véritable vainqueur
c'est un coup d'état
tron fait un coup d'état pour voler ces
élections et c'est illégitime ils ont
arrêté les élections le soir du scrutin
pour pouvoir s'arrêter et aller chercher
des faux bulletins afin de pouvoir
gagner quand vous avez toutes ces
quantités de vote qui vont à des gens
dont vous ne savez même pas s'il devrait
être acceptée vous ne savez pas qui les
remplit vous ne savez pas qui les
renvoie cela devient donc un problème la
pennsylvanie est en effet au centre de
toutes les attentions
comptant parmi les swing states ces
états pivots qui selon l'élection font
pencher la balance côté républicain ou
démocrate
la pennsylvanie a changé huit fois
d'allégeance au cours des 100 dernières
années elle a d'ailleurs contribué à la
victoire de donald trump en 2016 après
24 ans de fidélité au camp démocrate
c'est aussi le cinquième état le plus
pourvus en grands électeurs celui qui
remporte la pennsylvanie remporté 20 des
538 vote du collège électoral si byden
rafle son état natal à trump la victoire
lui serait assuré d'où les crispations
autour du scrutin à l'origine de ces
tensions le nombre de votes par
correspondances envoyées dans les
bureaux pennsylvanien des millions de
bulletins qu'il faut dépouiller
or ces votes par correspondance favorise
le candidat démocrate dont le score
augmente au fil des heures
donald trump lui préfère y voir une
fraude des accusations rejetées par
l'exécutif local c'est un cas où il
essaie de voler une élection il essaie
de truquer une élection au système de
vote et nos bases de données font en
sorte qu'aucun électeurs ne puissent
voter plus d'une fois
littéralement un frein si jamais
quelqu'un essayait la bataille autour du
scrutin en pennsylvanie a d'ailleurs
failli virer au drame ce jeudi soir la
police de philadelphie a arrêté deux
hommes qui projetait de s'attaquer à
l'un des bureaux de vote de la ville
preuve des tensions qui règnent au sein
d'une amérique plus que jamais divisée
et le dépouillement ne suscite pas
détention qu'en pennsylvanie l'arizona
où la géorgie sont également concernés
la géorgie où certains électeurs sont
prêts à défendre leur candidat les armes
à la main ils trichent clairement les
démocrates ont des morts qui votent pour
eux ils font cela à chaque fois cette
fois nous ne supporterons pas si vous
savez que quelque chose ne va pas le
verrou si vous sentez que sa vache
rejoignez votre milices locales les
résultats de l'élection sont donc
suspendus au dépouillement de quelques
dizaines de milliers de bulletins
ironie du sort le vainqueur en
pennsylvanie pourrait bien s'installer à
la maison blanche située à washington au
1600 pennsylvania avenue